okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of uh history of science and
technology q a
um so we seem to have
questions left over but i'm happy to try
and talk about
uh history of things about science or
technology
either things that i've personally been
involved in and where i personally know
the people involved in those things or
the computers for that matter
and things from the more distant past
that i might have studied uh mostly in
connection with things that i figured
out myself
all right there's a question here from
carop that i see was left over
which was what does history have to say
about combating anti-science movements
wacky conspiracy theories especially
when it comes to more dangerous ones etc
um
you know it's an interesting thing
people have wacky theories all the time
it comes with the species
you know in the middle ages there were
some particularly wacky theories at
least from our point of view now about
how
oh i don't know i'm sure there were um
all kinds of um
uh
you know not from the middle ages but
you know there's loch ness monsters
there's bigfoots there's
uh well there's the dinosaurs on the
rocks what were the dinosaurs and the
rocks well actually it turns out they
were um sorry dinosaurs dragons and the
rocks
uh you know people people found you know
the skeletons of dragons well turns out
eventually there was a scientific
explanation for that it was dinosaurs uh
you know
from 65 million years ago or more
so
i mean it's a complicated thing because
people are always coming up with these
theories about how things work
that
uh sometimes go off into utter wackiness
and sometimes those wacky theories turn
out to be true
other examples continental drift people
had noticed you know the shape of africa
fits in a jigsaw puzzle to the uh shape
of south america and then there were
theories uh particularly oh my gosh uh
wegener right i had this theory about
how um
the consonants must be drifting apart
and people like that theory is totally
nuts except it turns out it's true and
there are
all kinds of theories
that people have
that are sometimes thought to be nuts
and
and then turn out to be true i'll give
you other examples much there are a lot
of medical examples for example remember
the terrible idea of lobotomies
of the idea that oh well you can you
know people who have various kinds of
psychiatric problems
if you remove the frontal lobes of their
brains it'll make them better
now we think that is just completely
crazy
but for a while that was the scientific
orthodoxy of what to do
same with uh various forms i think this
has been better sort of uh refined but
various forms of electric shock therapy
with the same kind of idea where you
know scientifically proven to work
except as it turned out later utterly
wacky or at least from our point of view
today utterly wacky um one could say the
same thing another one that comes to
mind immediately
is is
i remember back in the day
not that long ago a few decades ago
people would say oh i need to avoid
stress the stress will give me stomach
ulcers
well that was the orthodoxy of how that
was supposed to work except it turns out
there had been people who said no no
stomach ulcers are really some kind of
bacterial infection or something and the
stress thing is just nonsense and people
say no no that's wacky you know that
they ignore that
um
and but turned out it was true
so
it's complicated and i i think
things uh for some reason
in some countries the u.s is
particularly notable for this
these theories that are sort of
scientifically proven and that end up
being you know medical solutions to this
or that people just go all in and they
just like this is it we're going to do
this
and
it uh
without any great kind of uh
uh
now you know
one it's a complicated thing because at
any given moment there is the best
theory we have and that's probably the
thing to go with but to say
two things to say not only it's one
thing to say it's the best theory we
have let's go with it because we don't
have any better idea and it's another
thing to say it's true it's true it's
true nothing else could possibly be true
that is usually a mistake
but it's a mistake that i think gets
made
with considerable frequency and over
time
as science has become sort of the
dominant
uh form of of rational discourse so to
speak um it's become something where
people say it's proven by science what
does that actually mean you know
sometimes that means
uh you know there were these studies
that were done that had some statistical
significance and that were done by
people who might have got them wrong
might have even gotten them wrong on
purpose who's to know um and that give a
particular result
so
then there's the question okay there's
the flip side of it let's say there
really are wacky things which cause
trouble okay people have wacky ideas
that don't cause a lot of trouble that
uh i would argue uh you know of of all
the different battles to fight that's
not one to fight
but let's let's take oh i could just go
on and on and on with these kinds of
ideas like like another one that was
popular a hundred and something years
ago was the idea of uh uh you know
physiogrammy right the the idea of um
you could tell the character of a person
by the shape of their head
another kind of
wacky idea um other uh but but you know
it's a wacky idea at some level but
probably there's some there's something
that you can tell
from
you know from some attribute of people
you can tell something you probably
can't tell
you know i'm sure you can't tell
something like you know if you imagine
okay here's another example actually
the whole idea of iq as a measure of
everything
isis is is kind of wacky idea but it's
an idea that became very well accepted
um and and the notion of
similar ideas about sort of segmenting
people based on one attribute or another
but people say look it's true you know
you can segment people on the basis of
this attribute or that attribute
um
it's
uh
you know
at some level
those kinds of theories end up causing
lots of trouble because
it's
ultimately not right but there are some
things that are you know if somebody is
seven feet tall they can reach a higher
shelf than somebody who is five feet
tall it's just the way it is
you know the person who's five feet tall
can learn how to climb on a stepladder
and reach you know an even higher shelf
probably but that's a different thing i
think one of the things that tends to be
the case
is that which people get confused by is
that the degree of universality of
capability of humans is probably
something that is not necessarily
intuitive and it reminds one of of with
computers that there's this notion of
universal computers you can have a fixed
piece of computer hardware and you put
different programs on it and it can do
different things
and i'm sure the same is true with us
humans with our brains and so on that
you can feed you know that that brains
will be different
you know one brain will have different
attributes from another and that could
be something that is genetic it could be
something that uh comes because of you
know what somebody ate when they were
very young or you know who knows what
it's due to but there no doubt are
physiological differences um and uh the
but nevertheless it's the case that to a
great degree not not probably perfectly
but to a great degree there's
universality in what can be achieved but
then of course there is the the the uh
the divergence of different people are
educated about different things and grow
up in different situations and so on and
so that again leads to divergence so
it's a it's a complicated thing to know
what what's correct but but i think
these these kind of
it tends to be a um
uh
you know when one makes a blanket
statements nothing like that could
possibly be true
um that is
very rarely a correct scientific
conclusion
the statement this is the best we know
right now we should go with it
is often a very sensible thing but
recognizing that
there are you know that it is probably
not as absolute as one things now if one
if one looks at the question of uh
um
things that where people have believed
wacky things
where a substantial number of people
have believed wacky things and that's
caused a lot of trouble in the world one
doesn't have to look very far to find
examples of that
whether
one is looking at um
oh i don't know all sorts of them i mean
probably some of the more damaging ones
societally have been related to eugenics
and so on um particularly that was a a
popular belief back in uh the early part
of the 20th century
um and uh you know if we can if we can
breed chickens we can breed humans type
thing
which
people generally think is a really bad
idea um of course
you know it it
and so the question then is if
i think i think one has to separate out
different kinds of things
they're things where
the science is just obviously wrong
from things where
there may be some science to it but it's
a societally really bad idea in other
words the the the the consequence of
saying uh you know we we could do this
the science is not wrong i mean you
could say
you could make a claim like
it is
uh let's see what's a good example
um
well there are plenty of examples where
we can imagine issues
so you could say
um
oh it's a good example well
the um
i i think
the history of kind of the
the um
defeat of wacky ideas
i i would say
i'm just trying to think of examples i
mean there's so many wacky things people
have done and people have believed i
mean i don't know i for some reason one
that i'm remembering is some
uh oh i don't know like like x-raying
children's feet to find out the size of
shoes they should have
that was a thing that was when i was a
kid that was still being done and
routinely so
and then people realized that it's not a
very good idea because that's a bunch of
x-ray exposure
or similarly you know watches with
radium dials that glowed at night
through radioactivity another example of
a bad idea now people would say
wait a minute that's not a good idea and
to some people that was like oh that's
wacky you know that's a fringe kind of
thing and the question is how did
how did the um uh i'm trying to think of
other examples where people i mean there
are plenty of times where what was
mainstream was actually quite wacky
and the question is how did that sort of
get uh get resolved and i think in many
of those cases it got resolved rather
quietly
other cases perhaps not so quietly i
mean i don't know i'm thinking of um
i mean the the general category of
things which end up being
this seemed like a good idea at the time
but actually wasn't a good idea
one category is things which had
unintended consequences i don't know for
some reason i'm thinking asbestos
uh insulation which turned out to have
the very bad consequence of having these
little fibrous things that get in
people's lungs and cause all kinds of
trouble
and and cancers and so on um
but uh i think um and other kinds of
diseases and such like but uh i think
that the um
uh that was sort of a an unintended
consequence of something i'm trying to
think more about theories where there
was a set of people who had this theory
it was quite wacky it caused trouble
um but the theory was um yeah i mean i
suppose there are there are plenty in
the area of eugenics
and um
i think
uh
and there are
you know sometimes
some of these theories it's
people come up with kind of the logical
argument for why this has to be true
and um
um
it's it's like um
uh
yeah it's a good question how
how
kind of um
uh obviously wacky ideas
um end up
um you know sometimes there's an event
like for example
one that there's a bit more complexity
around it
is uh you know the the scopes trial from
what the 1920s 1930s 1920s i guess
in the us
of um uh you know could
uh
you know should you teach evolution
darwinian evolution in schools or was
the right theory the purely biblical
theory
you know the literal biblical theory
about you know the fossils are put in
the rocks type thing and the world is
calculated to be six thousand years old
um
and you know in a case like that
the
the the sort of the denumer of that
story was a kind of very publicly
visible
showdown i suppose the same thing
happened to some extent with um
some of darwin's um
work and um his bulldog huxley who he
sometimes complained didn't really
understand his theories very well
but um was a great bulldog so to speak
and the famous um debate between uh
huxley and uh
bishop wilberforce um i actually once
gave a talk in the
the very same room in the natural
history museum in oxford where that
debated had taken place
um
the uh
but in which um
the uh that was became a very celebrated
moment
for
uh kind of the evolution against
the as people might think kind of the
the forces of of um the non-scientific
forces so to speak
um and i suppose there are these kind of
moments where where there's sort of a
showdown and things happen
um i would say that
you know an interesting question i mean
where when i'm i'm trying to think about
other
examples
where people have
um
uh
i'm i'm going to
avoid um
i could give a long discussion about uh
the anti-vaccine movement and
vaccines and immunology and so on but
we'll leave that for another day
um it's one of these things where i
think the main thing to say is
absolutism is almost never correct
um on the other hand there's a best
thing that one knows at the time
and that's worth
going for but it's um it's one of these
things where
um
it um
uh
i i think
i i think there is a there is a
as i say a great tendency to say
it's either a wacky theory or it's not
and
i think that's
almost never correct that it's something
where there's absolutely no truth to it
now sometimes
like
uh
you know something like the earth is
flat
okay there's absolutely no truth to that
the uh the sun goes round the earth
hmm
obviously
you know if we think about
i mean amusingly enough
in some ways galileo himself famous for
having sort of pushed the copernican
idea of no no the earth goes around the
sun
uh invented this thing called galilean
invariants which is the idea i see i
think galileo described it you know if
you're in a on under
you know in a ship and you're you know
everything's sort of blacked out and the
ship is moving around
can you tell
uh you know can you tell what's moving
what's not
now in the case of earth going around
the sun there's a difference because of
acceleration because it's being kept in
a circular orbit and so on but the idea
of the earth is is you know the sun is
staying still and the earth is moving
versus the earth is staying still and
the sun is moving well guess what
galileo himself invented this idea of
galilean variants that says you kind of
can't tell the difference between those
two things but yet
that you know much was made out of the
kind of the obvious foolishness
of uh the um the you know the the
the different view of how things work
now okay there were other parts to that
story um but it's it's again
somehow
the uh uh i don't know i'm i'm not a
great believer in
in the conclusion that i i mean i should
say another thing which is that
it is often the case
that
widely held seemingly wacky theories
have some element of truth to them
not the whole thing the whole thing may
be utterly wacky
but the um
uh you know but there's something there
that isn't you know where
where
you know where where one shouldn't just
say no no it's absolutely not true now i
think somebody else was asking here
about
about um uh yes gray-headed aliens
um how come to people come to believe in
gray-headed aliens
hmm
yeah well that's an example of what
seems to me to be a completely wacky
theory
um you know it's uh
but i suppose i've i've um
another good example okay i'm i'm coming
up with more examples not very
systematically here another good example
is the whole extra sensory perception
business and
uh parapsychology and and uh all these
kinds of things
uh i i have to say i've seen some
examples of that
that are to my mind utterly wacky so the
common issue is you know can people can
humans communicate
telepathically and things like that is
there a way for kind of the thoughts of
one brain to be communicated in some
sort of magical fashion without you know
talking or other kinds of things you
know is that conceivable
well you know one could sort of work out
the electromagnetics of it and one could
say you know could it be the case that
electromagnetic you know electrical
uh
effects in one brain could could have
some effect on another brain it's a
really really really small effect it
probably can't work that way
is there some other thing that we don't
know about is it you know we really like
insects where we're you know generating
some strange pheromone molecule that is
somehow wafting through the air and um
uh and allowing sort of thoughts to be
communicated i think again it's one of
these things where where the absolute no
no no there's no possibility that
there's any form of of sort of
communication between brains that isn't
what we already know about that's
probably a mistake on the other hand
when people come and say look i've got
these examples of um
of cases where you know the person in
one room is looking at the cards and the
person in the other room is somehow
visualizing these cards
and you start kind of homing in on is
that really true do you really get that
usually you get a sense quite quickly of
whether the kind of the the setup is one
that has sort of reality to it or not
and i think that the um uh the thing
that um i remember years ago a person
who was actually a
a perfectly known engineer
academic engineer
had this whole
extra sensory perception thing going
and i remember asking the question
because it all seemed very implausible
to me but but you know i'm not prepared
to just dismiss these things completely
out of hand
but so i asked the question
well what happens if i think it was
something where there was a question of
somebody being able to
uh
deduce
what was happening in some physical
system that seemed like it was doing
random things without ever having
measured it so i said well what happens
if the system is actually using a
pseudo-random generator is using
essentially a purely algorithmic process
to generate these numbers this
particular person didn't seem to
understand the notion of algorithmic
generation of randomness very well
so this was kind of an interesting data
point because
it was like can you run that experiment
where you instead of doing this
with a
uh you know with a with a physical
system i forget what it was but some
some physical system where it's you know
some fluid
floating around and you know you get uh
you know does this piece of the lava
lamp end up being this color or that
color and that's how you generate it and
the person is kind of uh imagining is
being able to uh sort of extra sensorily
predict what's going to happen so okay
what happens if it actually is
algorithmic it's determined okay so the
experiment was done
and turns out the effect stayed
and it's like how could this possibly be
how could it possibly be
that
that
this person oh no that's right that's
right i'm sorry i misremembered a piece
of this the idea was that the person was
influencing
this
uh lava lamp or whatever it was to
produce the result they produced
and the whole point was if it's
algorithmically determined there is no
possibility of influencing anything
and so then you have to kind of pivot
the whole story and the pivoted story
was some strange thing about premonition
rather than rather the manipulation of
physical things but at that point as far
as i'm concerned you know the train has
left the station the thing is the
thing's gone that that's not a good a
good theory
you know i have to say
another example of a wacky theory is the
cold fusion business i mean i remember
when that first
sort of came on the scene
um i wasn't directly involved in it but
uh
i i always thought
you know you start asking about it okay
there's this palladium electrode and
it's got all this hydrogen and it's
being um and somehow the hydrogen atoms
are getting close enough that they can
undergo fusion which
usually is something that requires them
to be pushed together with very high
high energy high temperature um although
you can get small amounts of fusion in
in other kinds of ways but but that that
you know usually you'd have to put make
a whole giant you know uh fusion reactor
to do this and yet in this experiment
there was you know fusion seemed to be
happening
and you know at first it's like well
that's that's odd then you start
realizing well actually palladium is a
substance that dissolves huge amounts of
hydrogen in it so it's like there is
actually a pretty high concentration you
can get pretty high concentrations of
hydrogen in palladium so it's like not
completely you know not completely crazy
but then
for whatever reason
the the sort of science establishment
people tried to reproduce these
experiments they didn't succeed in
reproducing them um and the science
establishment just said this is wacky
it's wrong
we're out of here you know this is all
all a fake
um
you know who knows
i i have to say i think that the
probability is certainly not a hundred
percent that that's the correct
conclusion
and
like all experiments where you say we
can't reproduce the experiment the
experiment has to be wrong well you know
what exact conditions were you under you
know we don't know the the you know the
exact conditions maybe it mattered that
it was in
a
a room that got direct sunlight where
the experiment was being done because it
really mattered that there was this
frequency of light or maybe it really
mattered that that was a room that was i
don't know what you know a zillion
different things one just doesn't know
what really matters and in a good
science experiment physical science
experiment you know you try to sort of
insulate things as best you can and have
as few sort of confounding effects as
possible but it's always hard to know
anyway a not very satisfactory answer
perhaps because i don't really know a
great great answer to this question
about uh when first first thing i would
say is
when you say the theory is wacky
it's i'm always a bit
a bit nervous about saying definitively
that theory is wacky
um i mean i'm sort of amused by things
where people have said about things i've
done in the past oh that's totally wacky
except it turns out in a decade or two
well actually it turned out that's just
everybody agrees that that's how it
actually works and you can tell that's
how it actually works but at the
beginning people are like oh that's not
what people thought was true it has to
be completely wacky so
you know this happens with some
regularity and and i have to say i think
it's a mistake to just sort of say
because most people kind of vaguely
think it's wacky
then it has to be completely wacky i
mean think for yourself type thing and
try and learn about it if you have to
make a definitive decision based on
knowing is it wacky or not
but in the case of things that are sort
of um
in case of things that are definitely
not true
um
you know how do those how do those ideas
end
it's actually pretty complicated i think
i think
sort of incorrect theories
die rather slowly
i mean i think that people
in in people have a remarkable ability
to sort of continue and i've seen this
people will spend their whole careers
uh you know they've had they've been
working on something and the theory just
isn't working but they keep trying to
push it they keep trying to push the
thing and they keep doing it for their
whole career even though this theory and
usually that's those academic theories
that are they're not quite as extreme
um as as uh you know the gray-headed
aliens type theory and and so on but
it's some uh people will just keep keep
on these theories for the rest of their
careers so to speak i think it is
something you know the end of a theory
the the everybody agrees this theory
isn't true
i think the most common reason that
theories end is when there's a better
theory which sort of takes on the
applications of the previous one
and
and sort of goes from there so to speak
i mean i'm sure there were theories of
genetics before dna and the digital
information of dna was known
i'm sure there were theories about how
genes work i probably even know some of
those theories
that were just
washed away because there was a
definitively better theory that could
sort of power through all of those
phenomena and i guess that's the that's
the thing that um is probably the best
theory ender is a better theory so to
speak which really can take on the
applications of the previous theory but
in terms of
of uh you know could oh i don't know i i
love some of these theories that are
just quite wacky i mean you know could
the earth actually be hollow and um you
know there'd be dinosaurs living inside
type thing
well you know that's um the answer is
presumably absolutely not we have you
know seismic waves that propagate
through the earth we know what the
density of the earth is but now you ask
me a question like
could there be
uh microorganisms that exist
30 miles down in the crust of the earth
i don't know
i don't think they've been observed
can i say definitively there can be no
microorganisms that live 30 miles down
in the crust of the earth
i don't think that will be a sensible
thing to claim
could i claim there could be no life
in the mantle of the earth for example
where it's very hot
well my guess is the chemistry of life
as it exists on the surface of the earth
doesn't make it at all at those
temperatures
but to say there could be nothing
like that i mean people thought
hydrothermal vents in the ocean couldn't
support life they had too much sulfur
and all kinds of other things turns out
that wasn't true um again i would say
that the the big lesson of the history
of science is uh things where one says
it's absolutely impossible
usually
that's not correct
and things where a lot of people where
there's an intuitive belief that things
work some way i'll give you an example
from my own work in recent times
so
people
uh we talk about time we talk about
space
for the last hundred years a lot of
people have said well really time is
just a fourth dimension just like space
they're really the same kind of thing
and a lot of kind of thought experiments
and kind of descriptions are given where
it just seems like you can talk about
time and space in the same way
the real history of that you know i
think albert einstein when he invented
relativity back in
1905 i don't think he was that big on
the space and time and really the same
kind of thing he understood things about
the relationship between space and time
but saying space and time are really the
same kind of thing i don't think was his
i think that actually came from uh uh
hermann winkowski
in 1909 ish
who
was a number theorist
and who observed that in einstein's
theory of relativity the invariant
distance between points is beautifully
given as x squared plus y squared plus z
squared minus
c squared the speed of light squared
times t squared so it's a beautiful
quadratic form of the form you know x
squared minus t squared and minkowski
has studied quadratic forms quadratic
forms are are a big thing in mathematics
gauss did a lot of work on them around
1800 or so
um you know the idea of a quadratic form
is something like you know from the
pythagorean theorem we know
that uh you know the length of the
hypotenuse is you know x squared plus y
squared so to speak square root of that
um and those these quadratic forms show
up all over the place and they show up
also in relativity theory as this
invariant distance and so that was
minkowski was very into it's a quadratic
form and then that gave the idea that
well it's a quadratic form it just has
these variables x and t
and there's transformations that
preserve the quadratic form and x and t
must really work like in the same kind
of way and so for a long time and
certainly that's what i believed when i
was when i was doing physics earlier
earlier on that space and time same kind
of thing there's just lorentz
transformations that are rotations
between space and time just like we can
have a rotation in three-dimensional
space
that's one of the things one one
realizes isn't right with our uh
recent theory of physics because what
turns out to be true is that time
i'm really quite certain is true is that
time is kind of the inexorable progress
of computation and space
is a feature of the way that the
different elements of the universe are
kind of knitted together by by sort of
uh common relations so to speak
and so they're really different kinds of
things it turns out that relativity
theory is still true for slightly subtle
reasons having to do with the way that
observers observe just causal
connections between events and things
like this but from an intuitive point of
view the notion that look science has
proved space and time the same kind of
thing that's the end of the story turns
out it's not true and it turns out that
that believing that as an absolute thing
was actually something that probably
impeded the progress of science by at
least a solid number of decades
um and uh so you know i think these are
these are things where and what's
interesting about that one is to most
people space and time really don't seem
like the same kind of thing you know you
move around in space
you you just progress through time
inexorably you don't get to be a time
traveler i mean you know h.g wells and
so on had written his uh you know time
machine book in the what the end of the
1800s um and that was kind of a a um
this idea of you can travel in time is a
kind of an interesting conceptual idea
but it's not an idea that we have
experience with and it's not an idea
that's really true
um
so in any case
um
let's see there's a long answer to that
um
question another one from carob um
the counterculture movement is sometimes
associated with renewed interest in
quantum mechanics in the 60s
would richard feynman who lived in that
area
in that era have agreed
um
you know
let's go through a little bit the
history of quantum mechanics
so
the big sort of explosion of discovery
in quantum mechanics was in the 1920s
with
heisenberg's on sunday principle the
schrodinger equation
matrix mechanics wave mechanics all
these kinds of things
there had been precursors the biggest
precursor was probably the idea of
photons from max planck in 1900
and then the realization of einstein's
that photons were worth thinking about
as real kinds of things
what happened historically was people
were looking at
black body radiation that is you have a
a cavity a black box and you heat it up
and as it gets hotter eventually it will
glow
the black painted box or whatever will
start glowing red hot then white hot
then blue heart
that's that is the the black body
spectrum black body radiation is
associated with uh temperature and there
was this thing called wean's law which
was a law that governed some of the some
of the distribution of frequencies for
the radiation produced at a certain
temperature
but the data didn't quite fit that and
max planck back in 1900
found a different fit to the data not
something which would be a pure
exponential but something which is one
one over
uh e to the temperature
uh
uh minus one
minus one i got the right way around yes
minus one yeah um
and uh
i got that the right way around was it
plus one oh my gosh
um
one of them is fermions one of them is
bosons and uh let's see
yeah yeah it should be minus one for
that um in any case so you know that was
something that planck at first
discovered as a pure kind of numerical
coincidence oh look
you you know this fits better but by the
way
if this
the the way to understand how you get a
formula like this
is if there were discrete
uh quanta
of
of radiation of of of of light of of um
uh associated with this with this um
uh
that it was it was a sort of a
complicated story of there were atoms in
the walls of the of the container that
were emitting and absorbing
uh
the the radiation and if that happened
in a discrete way where there were
discrete quanta of light effectively
then then you would be able to fit the
observed data so it was initially a very
empirical kind of thing
and then einstein noted that the
photoelectric effect when you
uh have a photon of the right frequency
it can emit it can on a metal you can
get an electron ejected um
observed that oh that would work if
there really were photons if there were
really were some kind of quanta of light
particles of light much like electrons
that were then known that have been
discovered by jj thompson
in uh
1890 something or other the existence of
electrons
and then uh uh
um well
that and electrons were by that point
things like cathode ray tubes were known
it was it was a this idea that you could
have that electrons were discrete things
and so then it was not that many years
later that einstein observed based on
what planck had figured out with the
planck spectrum of blackberry radiation
that yes you should think about the
photons of light as also being discrete
things
it was then another oh
a couple of decades later that people
really got the mathematics of these
things straightened out that was a
development that happened through people
like um uh people um rutherford
understanding that they were atomic
nuclei and then people having these
models of the atom that were initially
the i think thompson had a
jelly model of the atom so to speak
where it's sort of a nucleus and then
there was electrons sort of in a in a
jelly around the nucleus and then then
it became clear that there was uh you
know niels bohr had a had a different
theory but but these were
that that that sort of was a a gradual
progression towards quantum mechanics
and then in in the 1920s this
mathematical formalism which was at the
time like for example werner
heisenberg's formulas in the matrix
formalism matrices were the category
theory of their day so to speak they
were the kind of high tech of
mathematics of that time kind of out in
the abstract frontier of how people
thought about mathematics
uh differential equations of the kind
that schrodinger used were much more
familiar um but one of the questions was
the um
the question of okay so you could write
down these equations you could predict
things from these equations what was the
meaning of these equations
and people like max born for example
said oh we can just interpret
the um
uh the the wave function
that shows up in children's equation the
the the modulus squared of the wave
function is the probability what did
that really mean
well
it was complicated what that meant and
it didn't matter much when you computed
things you were computing probabilities
of things you were computing the
intensity of the spectral line you were
computing the probability of the
scattering process
uh you know you just used this
prescription for calculating things and
most of the real work was in calculating
the wave function and then the
interpretation of oh it's the wave
function squared that gives the
probability was kind of a an
afterthought
now von neumann john von neumann
in the
1930s i guess
uh decided to kind of mathematicize
quantum mechanics
and to make a kind of a formal axiomatic
system out of quantum mechanics i have
to say that when i was working in
quantum field theory in the 1970s and so
on
nobody ever talked about that stuff
nobody cared the the axiomatization
of um of sort of quantum mechanics done
by von neumann there were a few ideas
like the density matrix i'm not sure if
that was actually from von neumann but
it was from that general circle of ideas
people did use density matrices they
were they were relevant they were useful
particularly in looking at particular um
the interaction of quantum mechanics and
statistical mechanics and so on but
people were not really discussing the
interpretation of quantum mechanics in a
terribly serious way in the 1970s it was
a very fringe area
where it was really oh yes there are
some philosophers who are interested in
the interpretation of quantum mechanics
and then how it can be the case that
only the probabilities come out et
cetera et cetera et cetera but in terms
of the physics crowd it was just let's
just calculate stuff and that's that's
good enough for us
so
i think the um
uh people like david bowm
who i never met um who was one of the
people involved in sort of uh
kind of a a different view of how to
interpret quantum mechanics and so on uh
primarily in the 1960s i guess
and boehm had a had a complicated
personal history uh american who
was involved in i i'm gonna get this
wrong but i think he was a
i think he was an anti-war person um i
could have that wrong and and wound up
um in in different um
uh
parts of the world and so on um
just i think that was a complicated kind
of personal story then there was a uh
but there were there were a limited
number of people who were really
interested in the interpretation of
quantum mechanics and in sort of the the
meaning of things and in
um in that type of thing when it comes
to for example quantum computing
i can tell you a bunch about the history
of that because because i was there so
to speak
um
back
i think
well before my time
dick fineman
in the late 1950s
gave a talk at the optical society of
america it's one of these things that
happens to me
uh
with some regularity you know some
slightly
un
not what you usually work on group
will say oh can you give a talk about
the relevance of what you're doing to
something or other like tomorrow i'm
giving a talk about biomedicine which is
something that's not specifically what i
usually work on but for me it's
interesting to give talks like that
because it gets me to think about those
kinds of things and to think
are the things that i'm doing actually
relevant in in those areas and so on um
and uh so
dick fryman back in 1959 i think um gave
a talk with the i think the optical
society of america
and um it was about i think it had a
title like there's lots of room at the
bottom or something and it was about
miniaturization and uh the question of
of kind of uh you know how small could
you make stuff and and of course
you know for dick fineman who'd worked
on quantum electrodynamics and um was
very much a quantum kind of person um
you know he had to talk about quantum
mechanics there and he did i don't
remember exactly what he said there but
that was a kind of an early seed it was
also an early scene for the kind of
nanotechnology
world
then many many many years went by
and i don't think much was ever
discussed about quantum mechanics and
computers part of the reason for that
was physicists didn't really believe in
things like turing machines in a certain
sense
physicists used computers yes not very
much but but well some of them used them
more than others but you know in if
you'd asked a physicist in the 1970s
does the universe compute things
or an are turing machines relevant to
the description of the physical world
most physicists would have said no
definitively not
turing machines are discrete systems
that have are digital and the physical
world is analog it's full of
differential equations and continuous
numbers and all these kinds of things
and it really wasn't those two things
were really thought of as separate so
the idea that sort of quantum mechanics
something very much from physics would
merge with something that was very much
from engineering and from sort of
theoretical science
um the uh
that just really wasn't a thing and so
i remember
back well i certainly talked to dick
feinman at length about
about quantum computers and i can't
remember
how
we got started talking about that i
remember
spent a whole bunch of time on that
i remember i'm sure i still have them
somewhere all kinds of all kinds of
printouts i have of solving schrodinger
equations for
spin chains
and some of
feynman's notes about trying to
calculate what would happen for spin
chain spin chains that is a a chain of
electrons where where they each have an
inter
in a line where the electrons each have
some interaction with each other that
was the favorite model that we looked at
and you know i'm just wondering and i i
don't remember this history very well
maybe
that was after i started looking at
cellular automata which are which i was
also looking at as discrete chains of
things
and uh maybe maybe that's what happened
and maybe um
um
the
let's see maybe that's what happened i
think another person in that picture was
a chap called ed fredkin who i've known
for many years who is a sort of um i
would say a a gentleman physicist of
some kind um a long time he's had a had
an interesting life um it was
a i think he he was um
grew up in new york city in a in a very
um
kind of uh amateur science infused
uh environment
and uh wound up going briefly to caltech
i think and dropped out joined the air
force
became a test pilot
um then um this must have been in the
some time in the 50s and then at some
point
was some 1950s
at some point was
sent
to
do things with computers for the air
force
and
the result of that was that he spun off
a company that was doing
various kinds of i think aerial imagery
analysis
and later uh kind of computer graphics
things the company called information
international incorporated based in los
angeles
um and was i believe it was the company
that first made the cbs eye animation
that was sort of there um and uh uh the
um among among other things it was a
company that actually had a lot of
interesting people involved with it it
um it had i think ed's ed's partner in
that company died and that caused a
whole destabilization of the company and
so on and so ed himself went off got
recruited by mit to be the sort of
administrative head
of the um
lab for computer science
and um did all kinds of things there
worked a bunch with marvin minsky uh ai
pioneer but ed had had this idea
back from when he was working at bulk
brannika newman which was a consulting
ish company in boston that was very
involved in the early
creation of the arpanet later the
internet back in probably 1958 1959
something like that
ed
had gotten interested in
what in in basically two-dimensional
cellular automata and it started on the
pdp-1 computer or something simulating
some of these things
and ed
and i'm sure he's told me this story and
i'm not um i'm not able to immediately
tell you where this came from but
but ed
had um
gotten convinced that the universe must
be a giant cellular automaton and i have
to say
for all of the positive things that ed
might have done
the fact that ed has spent
sort of his life saying the universe is
a giant celery automaton
is at least for me a science inhibitor
rather than a science enhancer because i
have always thought the universe is not
a giant cellular automaton but people
look at work i've done on cellular
automata and look at work i've done on
physics and say wait a minute are you
saying the universe is a giant cellular
automaton
well
no
absolutely not
the
the thing about cellular automata is
they have a completely rigid view of
space and time and one of the things
that took me a while to understand this
but by the 1990s i was starting to
understand this
was that the the actual
a fundamental model of physics has to be
based on something underneath the kinds
of views of space and time that we have
and these ideas of hypergraphs and
networks and so on that are now the
basis for our model of physics those are
the more flexible version of one's view
of space and time and saying no no it's
a cellular automaton it's got a grid of
cells that doesn't cut it
but in any case
the um uh ed had long had this
conviction that cellular automata and
sort of discrete
well and and sort of this this idea of
just like a digital computer physics
must work
um
was something that originated for him a
very long time ago
he um
uh when he was at mit
he got several other people they're
involved in
in um in sort of working on this kind of
concept that physics might be like a
cellular automaton the result of this
was a bunch of very interesting things
about reversible computing the fredkin
gate for quantum computing all these
kinds of things which originally was
invented for reversible computing for
classical reversible computing a lot of
good spin-offs there um
but um
ed fredkin got to know dick feynman
fairly well
and um
the um uh and so i think there's there's
some uh sort of uh process by which
some of feynman's interest in well
no no that was a bit later um
by
1980
feynman also thought that the universe
as a cellular automaton was a wacky idea
um
and uh
but
i'm trying to remember how
i'm having a hard time remembering
exactly how
um
the discussion about quantum computers
originated i think yes i i remember i
remember now
right so there was a
a bunch of interest around 1980
in this physicalization of computers
not so much
the universe and physics
as a computer but computers being
thought of in physical terms
and so one of the questions had been
could computers operate reversibly
that is
usually when if you have
an and gate for example it has two
inputs one output that means it loses
information that's kind of a proxy for
the fact that if it's run as a
thermodynamic system it will uh
essentially generate heat it will
dissipate information and john von
neumann had believed that
information that that kind of
dissipation was a necessary feature of
being a computer in fact he believed
that sufficiently strongly people
started people like zillard started
talking about how a maxwell's demon
which is kind of a little little critter
that's
a conceptual critter that's kind of un
sorting molecules in just the way
thermodynamics says you shouldn't be
able to do was arguing oh you can't do
that because the computer that's
basically running the daemon has to has
to generate
more um more heat and so on and people
believed that that doing computing was
necessarily a a thing for which you had
to dissipate heat
well
uh a person called ralph landauer at ibm
um was very interested in that question
and a young fellow
then young person called charles bennett
um who had been a um
i guess he'd been uh he'd worked a bunch
on on um sort of
questions like how do you pack spheres
of different sizes together and things
like this but anyway he he got
interested this must have been uh
1973-ish time frame in the question of
whether you could make a reversible
computer
and um uh ended up
figuring out that yes
uh and he had a quite complicated scheme
in which with molecules and so on you
could imagine making a reversible
computer a computer where you could run
it one way and then you could just
reverse everything it had done and run
it back the other way
well
ed fredkin somewhat independently i
think
got into the same idea of doing
reversible computing
and
that idea of reversible computing was
sort of necessary
for thinking about quantum computing
because quantum mechanics if you don't
do quantum measurements quantum
mechanics is a fundamentally reversible
setup that is that which can run
forwards in time can also run backwards
in time
so but by
19
let's see i think the beginning must
have been
1982-ish timeframe
uh dick feynman had been talking about
oh can you make computers with quantum
mechanics i talked to him about that
a person called paul benioff who worked
at
argonne national lab
had
written
at least one paper about
quantum turing machines and i know about
that paper because i recently found the
referee report that i wrote for it for a
journal called physical review letters
in which
i actually i tweeted out that report
that i found i also sent it to paul
benioff who's still um uh who's still um
around in his 90s
um and um
i have to say that i i think my
i was i was quite i and so many years
later i am uh i i wasn't um i wasn't
embarrassed by my my report on that
paper which basically said look the idea
of combining quantum mechanics with
turing machines is a good and
interesting idea which has not been done
and this paper is an interesting effort
at doing it but this paper is
unbelievably hard to understand and over
complicated and then i kind of gave in
that report my version of how to think
about kind of quantum computers and
quantum turing machines um i said the
author of this paper should really
revise it and make it much clearer i
don't think he ever did and and i'm
afraid that's probably why
his work is not as well known um but um
uh i think the question here was um
um
had to do with sort of counterculture
and quantum mechanics and i guess i was
explaining here that the idea of for
example quantum computers didn't really
get at all serious until the beginning
of the 80s and then it really just
languished for a long time
and a few people kind of were like oh
well yes in principle we could do this
and so on and there was a period of time
when somewhat amusingly ibm was really
pushing the idea of using joseph's
injunctions superconducting
quantum
magnetic devices
as a
as a way to do computing and i say
somewhat amusingly because i think the
modern sort of ibm quantum computing
push is also about joseph's injunctions
but at that time the quantum word wasn't
really discussed it was just like we're
going to do computing where instead of
having transistors made of silicon we're
going to have switches made of josephson
junctions and that was in the 80s i
think um but um
in any case the question of sort of the
interaction
of the counterculture movement with
quantum mechanics was the question here
and
my impression is that there was a
um
a
the interaction of that with physics
was not much at all
um the idea of interpretations of
quantum mechanics
was sort of something where oh the
philosophers talk about that
there were also people
in the kind of i would say californian
alt alt dot
world
who were
uh you know sort of grooving out
on
on things about you know oh the world's
all incomprehensible it's all quantum
mechanics
and it
you know we can imagine quantum
mechanics by taking psychedelic drugs or
something i don't know but um and it's
all incomprehensible now i have to say
that dick feynman did interact with a
bunch of those people
he enjoyed this thing it was called
esselen um
and uh
he he he never tried to convince me to
go to one of these things probably just
as well um although i guess once we went
to one of these things um okay one one
story i i have to tell i don't know
whether the the protagonists in the
story are um are still alive or not
um
there was a um
a movement called est which is a
californian kind of movement um
uh this was in the 1970s must have been
up to about 1980 ish
and it was a um
uh it was kind of a
um a sort of self-help
occulty self-help type movement i think
that probably wouldn't be an unfair
characterization
um
run by a chap called werner earhart um
who had been previously i think an
encyclopedia salesperson which uh
made sense given various
various features of the um
uh of how this worked
but um
the um i i think um
um
for some reason this must have been
1980.
um
werner erhardt
decided that he wanted to organize a
conference about theoretical physics
at his house in san francisco
and so he invited a bunch of people
including stephen hawking i remember was
there
and and dick feynman and myself
um and a bunch of other physicists i was
i was a young person back then i'm sure
i was by significant margin the youngest
person there
but the the sort of arrangement made
with the physicists
was that there wouldn't be any publicity
about this it would just be a sort of
private meeting that took place at the
verna earhart house in in somewhere in
san francisco
um and i think it was one of these
things where there were lots of
volunteers who were part of the s
movement who were uh very much you know
found it interesting interacting with
the physics crowd and i think it was
sort of an internal
um it wasn't
wasn't particularly a a um
um
uh
uh
i don't know it wasn't wasn't completely
clear what was going on so to speak why
this was i think it was more of a
a
kind of
show connection with intellectual things
for the internal crowd than it was
anything else but i remember there was a
dinner there
where um
for some reason dick feinman and myself
were kind of chosen by the physicists to
be the people kind of sitting opposite
the um uh the main host that's been a
hard guy um and kind of um talking to
him and it was an interesting
conversation of um uh although i have to
say that the the uh you know as i think
i learned after that conversation that
the no no no i learned during that
conversation this um uh this sort of the
the the a bit of the history of erhart
um and uh it all the kind of the the way
the whole thing
you know
sort of worked did make some sense but
but i remember after that dinner dick
feinman
coming in talking to me for just hours
and hours and hours about trying to
understand how did somebody like this
verna earhart guy how did he manage to
lead people in this way and you know how
did how did leadership work and so on
and uh i think brigham what young was
another big example that he had of sort
of uh um unexpected leadership as he as
he thought it was um and you know what
led the what allowed these people to
lead other people and convince them to
do things and in fact it relates to the
question earlier about sort of science
and and what makes sense and what
doesn't and him being sort of look
people you know
you can you know leadership can get
people to do things even when the facts
don't support what's being said and so
on but um it was a it was um uh but but
fireman told me
many times actually he just found
the kind of these these somewhat sort of
counter-culturally crowd um much more um
he just found them less stuffy and more
more something which would extend his
thinking about things rather than
talking to academics who would mostly
tell him you know have you read my paper
about this and um you know what about
this very technical thing which he
didn't know anything about i mean i
think i think dick feinman was very much
a person who had a certain set of
methods which were particularly kind of
19th century mathematics methods
actually which he was really good really
really good at using and wielding and um
was he was not very didn't really trust
these um these more recent things but i
think he he certainly enjoyed some of
the more
um
uh i know i remember him
telling me about his uh
um uh um
what's it called sensory deprivation
experiences
and how extremely strange those were and
um he had i i think through some of
these sort of alt-dot crowd had ended up
um hanging out in some you know sensory
deprivation tank type thing and was very
uh taken with with how strange that was
um and i think but but i i would say
that the the general mixing uh certainly
in my observation the general mixing of
the the physics crowd with the sort of
counter culture crowd i don't didn't see
that much i mean there started to be
books written which were more for a
popular audience
that sort of brought those two kinds of
things together and brought kind of
eastern
uh philosophy together with quantum
mechanics and i think david bohm who i
mentioned earlier was i think somebody
who was a kind of respected physicist
although sort of also pulling those
kinds of things together but i don't
think it was really a um
um
a thing that um um that was uh uh you
know i don't think there was a lot of
mixing there look i'm i'm supposed to go
off to something else here because um
um
i'm actually going to do another live
stream but i i really want to
just a lot of interesting questions here
um
oh it was a question from aaron did dick
finally ever prank me or pick a lock
that belonged to me
ah
i think i knew him when he was
past his pranking times
i don't really remember him
uh
doing that i mean he liked to do sort of
um
uh unusual
lively and useful things but not so much
on the pranking
side of things
uh
lock picking block picking do i remember
any
i think the number of times that
myself dick feinman and the lock
being
sort of together
have to have been very limited
so i don't think i had any opportunity
to see that
in action
i do one of the things i i regret a
little piece of of history that i i
because i'm always a techno type person
this was back in probably 1979-ish
time frame maybe 1978. um i had not been
in the u.s very long but you know at the
time you got your phone by renting it
from the phone company and there was
this extra thing you could get you can
get an answering machine rented from the
phone company as well so of course i had
to get one of those things but it was
quite useful but um that led to the the
amusing moment
of dick feynman calling my my home phone
and and getting this answering machine
and being just
sort of confused amused
and leaving this quite long
message
uh sort of expounding on on them on
having reached an answering machine
sadly
i i don't you know i'm sure it had a
tape in it and i'm sure that got
overwritten it would have been a nice uh
historical artifact to have talking of
of technology and so on i'm just going
to mention one one other thing here
because i i noticed um
someone asked about stan ulam
and messi asked about stan ulam and his
work on cellular automata
um
and um
and ulam's work on the manhattan project
i noticed that a movie just came out um
about stan ulam which i have not yet
seen and i will probably see it in the
next week or so
um
i did know stan ulam and i can maybe
next time we do one of these i can talk
a bit about stan ulam um i'll uh by that
time i might be able to say with the
movie which is based on he wrote an
autobiographical book called adventures
of a mathematician um which i have to
admit i'm not sure that i've read but um
uh i certainly have a copy of it um
and um
the uh
um so
after after i've seen this movie i might
be able to give you some
some uh feedback on um on its accuracy
and uh of portrayal and also on them
the uh can tell you a bit about both the
general life and times of stan ulam and
um my interactions with him all right i
think i need to go
and uh
i'm doing a very different kind of live
stream about some practical
uh language design
um at the top of the next hour and i'm
i'm this is such a shame there are a lot
of really interesting questions here all
right we'll have fun the next time we do
this well thanks for all those questions
and um
bye